>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Karen Lloyd: Good morning
and thank you for joining us.
I'm Karen Lloyd, Director
of the Army's --
the Library's Veterans
History Project.
>> We'll take it.
>> Karen Lloyd: Today we
are in for a real treat.
With a nod to our upcoming exhibit
which opens on April 4th, 2017,
our American's entry into World
War I, appropriately named "Echoes
of the Great War, America's
Experiences of World War I,"
this interview with a current leader
of our military team
seems a good fit.
Today Colleen Shogan will have a
fireside chat with Eric Fanning,
the Secretary of the Army.
Since 2015 Colleen Shogan
has served as Deputy Director
of the Library's National
and International Outreach.
She joined the Library's
Congressional Research Service
in 2008 and served as the CRS Deputy
Director from 2012 until 2015.
Prior to joining CRS she worked for
two years on the Legislative Staff
of the Senate Armed
Services Committee.
She is also a published
author with three books
and many academic authors
to her credit.
Our special guest,
Secretary Eric Fanning,
has had an extraordinary career.
Secretary Fanning knows his way
around the Pentagon having served
in jobs as diverse as Chief of
Staff to the Secretary of Defense,
Acting Secretary of the Air Force,
Undersecretary of the Air Force
and Chief Management Officer,
Deputy Undersecretary of the Navy,
Deputy Chief Management Officer
acting under the Secretary
of the Army and Chief
Management Officer.
The enduring theme of
his assignments relate
to business transformation
and governance
to improve enterprise-wide
efficiencies.
He also spent time
in a Defense Agency
so he has first-hand experience in a
variety of aspects of the Department
of Defense that provide him
a [inaudible] of knowledge
that is rare and extremely valuable.
Secretary Fanning has also spent
time with a variety of Washington,
D.C. think tanks and
as a Research Assistant
with the House Armed
Services Committee.
It is understatement to say
we are fortunate to have
such a defense expert with us today
to help us better understand
the importance of diversity,
budget stability, and innovation.
Let's welcome them both with
a big round of applause.
[ Applause ]
>> Colleen Shogan: Thanks, Karen.
Good morning.
And to our, all of our guests,
welcome to the Library of Congress.
We've very privileged
and honored this morning
to host Secretary Fanning
here at the Library.
And the format for this morning --
We have about 45 minutes
for the conversation.
If there is time left over then
Secretary Fanning will take
questions from the audience.
Mr. Secretary, you've had,
just really as Karen said,
a tremendous career in the
Pentagon, largely in public service
in the public sector, but also
in the private sector as well.
Can you tell us when you first
became interested in defense policy
and when you knew that would
be the focus of your career?
>> Eric Fanning: Well
I think my interest was
in government and politics first.
I went to school in New Hampshire
and I actually arrived
as an Art Major.
I wanted to be an architect.
But when you go to school in New
Hampshire you're going to be there
for a presidential primary at
some point during your time.
And it's not a big state, not
a lot of places for them to go,
and they're there for a long time.
So you get to see the
process up close.
And I knew I wanted to come back.
I wanted to come to Washington.
So I -- an art major the first year
but come to Washington the summer
after my freshman year and then
hooked on politics, on the Congress
in particular, and was
sort of drawn to Defense
and Foreign Policy for
a number of reasons.
I have a pretty big military family.
My father grew up at West Point.
Two of his brothers,
brother-in-law went there.
And it all kind of
clicked because I got a job
in the House Armed
Services Committee.
And that just sort
of took off quickly
because within 16 months the
Chairman of the Committee
for whom I was working
became Secretary of Defense.
And so that was the -- the
path was set at an early point.
>> Colleen Shogan: Okay.
This is the Library of Congress.
We're very interested in
people who have had --
worked in the Legislative Branch.
So I'm going to ask a
little bit more about that.
You started your career at House
Armed Services and then, of course,
went on to have a very distinguished
career in the Executive Branch.
From the positions that you've held
in the Pentagon, when you look back
at your time in Congress, was
that very helpful to have had
that experience working
in the Legislative Branch,
and can you talk a
little bit about that?
>> Eric Fanning: It's very helpful.
It's also very fun.
I usually -- when I'm
advising younger people, I say,
go to the Hill early because
it's a relatively structure.
You can get a lot of
responsibility very quickly
and also tire of it very quickly.
But it's been helpful to me
in every job that I've had.
So much of what we do is
interacting with Congress,
our Board of Directors, essentially.
And there's so little
understanding outside of Congress
of how it actually functions and
how people think, how they operate,
and so -- I had one meeting before
coming over here this morning
and it was all about
Congressional issue and how
to move things through
our committees.
>> Colleen Shogan: Mm-hmm.
I have one more Congress-related
question for you.
The National Defense Authorization
Act, the NDAA, has been enacted,
I think, 55 years in
a row without fail.
And, as you know, in this time of
withering authorizations on the Hill
where it's very infrequent to see
authorizations, and certainly not
on a routinized scheduled,
can you share with us why you
think the NDAA has had its record
of continued passage and whether
you think that even this time
of extreme polarization and
partisanship on the Hill,
whether defense still
remains a bipartisan
or an even nonpartisan
issue with Congress?
>> Eric Fanning: Everything
is political
and partisan one way or another.
But it is a bastion of
across-the-aisle efforts,
the Armed Services Committee.
I think that the bipartisan
approach that we've taken
for national security for
decades and a point of pride
for those committees is what
drives in NDAA every year.
It is remarkably bipartisan
how those committees approach
their work.
I mean just my confirmation
process which was really --
the whole thing took place
on the Republican side --
the debate, the issues,
my supporters were on
the Republican side.
We make an effort to work
together across the aisle
to keep communication
open as much as possible.
And what I found -- it hit me really
in an unexpected way at the start
of the Obama Administration.
I was -- I worked in
the Clinton Pentagon,
was returning to the Iran Pentagon,
and it's a lot of the
same characters.
A lot of the people who I work
with in the Obama Pentagon I worked
with at an early point in all of
our careers in the Clinton Pentagon.
And a lot of names -- people on
the Hill, members in particular,
are people that were
around back then as well.
And so those relationships
survive and just evolve over time.
>> Colleen Shogan: Right.
That's interesting.
It's been years since I've
worked with Defense Policy
and worked in Armed Services.
But when I went back to prepare
for this interview I was surprised
at how many of the issues actually
had remained very consistent
and the same.
So you sat in many different
seats in the Pentagon.
You've worked in the Navy.
You've worked in the Air Force.
You've worked in the Sec-Def Office.
We're going to focus
today on the Army
because that's your
current position.
You talked a little bit
about your confirmation,
your confirmation hearing,
in particular.
You said that you were concerned
about decreasing Army end-strength.
But you also said that the Army
is more than just a number.
So I'd like to ask you about
what the future of the Army looks
like with a reduced force structure.
Is the Army going to continue to
be a conventional fighting force
or does it have to prepare for other
endeavors and other challenges?
And what does that mean for
the training of our soldiers?
Will they continue to be
trained as war fighters
or will they need additional skills?
>> Eric Fanning: So there's
about 12 questions in that.
>> Colleen Shogan:
Yeah, there's a lot.
>> Eric Fanning: I could pull
that one apart a little bit.
My confirmation hearing
I was more --
I was focused on making sure
that we were getting the
most combat capability
out of the force structure we have.
Maybe too nuanced.
But my own background in really
focusing on how we're organized,
how we're run, what the
processes are, to get as agile
and as efficient as possible,
so that whatever force
structure we're given,
whatever resource we're allotted,
that we're getting the most
bang for the buck out of it.
It was interpreted as me saying
we're cutting the Army too far
which caused me immediate
problems with my boss.
But we worked through that.
The Army is run hard.
The Military is run hard.
When we targeted this just
over 980,000 total Army --
the Active, the Guard, and the
Reserve -- Russia wasn't doing --
wasn't being as provocative
as it is now.
China wasn't flexing in
the way that it is now.
ISLE didn't exist as it does today.
And yet we're -- now we have all
those new requirements levied on top
of the force structure that
we were aiming towards.
What I would say -- two
things about force structure.
A raw number doesn't necessarily
tell you what an army is,
what capabilities an
army brings to a fight.
And it's very important
that we think
in terms of a balanced program.
It's not just people.
It's people that are
trained and equipped.
And if we're asked to keep more
force structure without an increase
in the budget in some way
then we have more people
with less training
and less equipment.
And that could easily quickly become
a larger army that's less effective
and less capable than the one
that we're trying to build now.
So the balance is important.
It's not just the number
of people that you have.
It's how they're organized,
how they're trained,
and how they're equipped.
As far as the future.
You now I think that the
broad requirements levied
on the Army now --
counter-insurgency,
counter-terrorism -- as well
as preparing for a larger fight
with a near-peer adversary, are
going to remain into the future.
The issue is how technology
changes, how the adversary changes,
and where you imagine the
environment you might be fighting is
changing or evolving, because
we know that we're on a trend
to increased urbanization and
mega-cities, which creates all sorts
of vulnerabilities for people
when they're clustered together
like that, which could
create something
on the back end of this trend.
But we've got to think about being
able to fight, increasingly fight,
in dense, urban environments
where the adversary is mixed
in with large civilian populations.
>> Colleen Shogan: Okay.
The most recent QDR, the Quadrennial
Defense Review, had a discussion
of risk based upon some
of the aging weapon --
major weapon systems in the Army,
the idea that we are still
technically advanced beyond
our adversaries.
But the gap between
the United States
and our adversaries is actually
decreasing, hence the risk.
I wonder if you could talk
a little bit about problems,
and everybody reads
about them in the news,
concerning the acquisitions process,
cost over-runs, delayed
deliverables.
What is the crux of the development
process, particularly in the Army?
And if you had more time as
Secretary, how would you fix it?
>> Eric Fanning: So I
think there are two things
when we're talking about that risk.
One is investment.
And the Army, with the nature of
the fights in the last 15 years,
has really been drawn into the day,
day after day after day after day,
and, as it should, making sure
that we have the size army we need
and that it is ready
for today's fight,
and that is men leveraging
the future in some ways.
And substantially cutting just in
the last eight years by upwards
of a third our modernization budget.
And so that's one part
of the growing risk
because we're not maybe
investing in modernization
in the way we should be, to think
about the future --
10, 15, 20 years out.
The second, of course,
is just the process,
the acquisition procurement process.
And the Army a decade
or so ago was grappling
with some very serious problems
across its portfolio programs
that were suffering from pretty
substantial cost overruns
and time delays.
It's easier now to say that
we have a better handle
on our acquisition programs
because we have a lot fewer of them,
and so they're easier to oversee.
But we've made a lot of changes
to the acquisition process.
If I had more time that
would be a primary focus
to keep working on that.
And a bit part of it's not just
changing what we do internally.
It is changing how we interact
with, and collaborate with,
work with those outside
the Department of Defense.
Technology is -- companies
and academic centers --
that they develop technology is a
different way than they used to.
It's very iterative now and we
aren't generally agile enough
to even keep up with that iteration.
I mean we all now have --
we're probably the last
people institutionally to hold
on to BlackBerrys because Apple
didn't want to work with us.
They said, you know, we put -- the
product is just one part of it.
The software, the updates, it all
is a package that goes together,
and you are not equipped
to receive our technology
and we just can't be bothered.
And so I think that's
a cautionary tale
for how we build, acquire things.
I think there's more we can
be getting off the shelf
and getting a [inaudible] faster.
But also about how we build
and acquire larger things.
>> Colleen Shogan: I'd like to give
you an opportunity to talk about one
of your major achievements as
Secretary which is standing
up the Rapid Capabilities
Office in the Army.
Can you tell everybody what
that is, what the structure is,
what goals you're hoping to achieve
with it, and why it's so important
to create -- give the
Army the ability
to create disruptive technologies
in the short amount of time?
>> Eric Fanning: So
there are a lot of --
you know, I say is there's
actually a lot of creativity
and innovation inside the
Department of Defense --
in uniform, in civilian workforce,
among our traditional
industrial base.
There's a lot of creativity
despite the barriers we've put
up in their -- in place of them.
So the Rapid Capabilities
Office really was --
in my job in the Air Force as
the Air Force Undersecretary,
which is the Number
Two, a lot of work
with the Air Force Rapid
Capabilities Office,
which is an enormous
organization because of all
of the black world programs
that are parked in the Air Force
and moved through this office.
The Army's version is
different and really was built
on what we were seeing, really
what we were seeing the Russians do
with Ukraine and realizing that they
had been watching us more closely
than maybe we'd been watching them,
that they had turned into a more
of a learning organization than
they had been during the Cold War,
and that the decisive edge we won
in capability maybe wasn't
what we had tracked it to be.
And so the way I describe our
Rapid Capabilities Office,
and nobody's allowed
to call it the RCO --
we're drawing a line at Acronyms
with the Rapid Capabilities Office
-- is that it fills a gap in time.
And I use a helicopter
as an example.
We're not going to enlarge the Rapid
Capabilities Office to something
that can build an entire helicopter.
But there might be some capability
on that helicopter that we need
to pull out and accelerate
to field it faster
for the existing fleet
that we've got.
And so we're really looking at a one
to five year time horizon
to plug gaps.
And I don't know -- in some cases
they're gaps and some places it's
to get that decisive
edge back in capability.
>> Colleen Shogan: Right.
>> Eric Fanning: And if
it's aligned right --
it's not meant to be a workaround
to the big existing
acquisition process.
We still need to keep
working on that.
But if these things are aligned
right, then the technology
and capability we can get out in
the Rapid Capabilities Office will
inform the more strategic
modernization that's taking place
over a longer term.
>> Colleen Shogan: So it's a
building block in other words.
>> Eric Fanning: It's
a building block, yeah.
>> Colleen Shogan: Due to frequent
deployments and repeated deployments
because of the global war on terror,
many service members
have come back obviously
with severe physical injuries,
but also have returned
with what is sometimes
called "invisible injuries,"
post-traumatic stress
disorder, depression.
The Army has endured for the
past several years an elevated
suicide rate.
Can you talk about that?
And what are the things that are
being put in place right now in Army
to try to solve that problem?
And are they addressing
the underlying problems
of culture and stigma?
>> Eric Fanning: So there's --
you know, I think there's a lot
of work being doing in this area.
There's a lot of focus on it.
There's a lot of attention on it.
There's a great deal
more to be done.
There's a lot of research
taking place.
The Army's partnering with a lot
of academic/medical communities
because we want to
understand this better.
And I think that the
stigma is changing.
But the more I think about this --
we've been focused on trying to get
behavioral health, behavioral care,
further out into operational
units so it's more accessible.
Someone doesn't have
to walk to the corner
of an installation to get help.
But it's just there.
But I think we need to further
radically shape the paradigm
which is not -- we're going to
provide care if you need it,
but you're going to need
care when you come back.
What we ask soldiers to
do on a regular basis,
deployment after deployment,
goes against how we're hardwired
biologically as human beings.
And so it shouldn't be it's there
if you need it, and we're going
to make it easy for you to find it.
It should be you're going
to need it and you're going
to get it when you come back.
It should just be a part
of the cycle we have,
much like how we maintain
tanks, for example.
If we run them hard, we bring
them back, we strip them down,
we put them back together.
The Special Operations Command
has actually done a lot of work
in this that's very interesting.
But I think in 10/15/20 years we're
going to look back on this time
and say wow, we really
missed a lot of things,
got a lot of things wrong.
And hopefully we'll have an
entire different way of looking
at behavior health that --
I would be frightened
to think we had an army
of people doing what we ask of them
and they're not impacted
by that mission.
I don't even want to know
what that would look like.
I wouldn't want to let that
loose on an adversary someplace,
particularly its environments
we're talking about.
And so I think we need to --
I think we're in the process
of looking at this differently.
But a lot more work has to be done.
>> Colleen Shogan: I want
to ask you a few questions,
two questions about
women in the Army.
Can you give us an update?
Where are we with the expansion
of women into all roles
in the Army including combat roles?
And where do you see the
challenges in that transformation
and that change for the Army?
And then, secondly, an issue that's
gotten a lot of attention her
on Capitol Hill in
the past several years
which is sexual assault
in the military.
What steps have been taken under
your watch as Secretary of the Army
to try to solve that problem?
>> Eric Fanning: So on the
first, women in combat --
I think things are going very well.
You know I always brag on the Army
on this one because I can do it
without -- because it's -- a lot
of great work was done before I got
to the Army to really analyze
what requirements are necessary
to do all the jobs across the Army.
And they are independent of
any qualifier of who you are.
They're real requirements based
on the equipment, the mission.
And then opening it up [inaudible]
to meet those requirements.
We made a decision in the Army to
build the leadership cadre first,
so to get new young lieutenants
in, to get enlisted, to re-branch,
you know, who have had
some experience so that
when we get brand new junior
soldiers in we've got leadership
in place to help make the
transition as smooth as possible.
And so the challenge, if you even
use that word "challenge" is just
that it was going to
take a little bit of time
to get some critical
mass going in there.
But I think it's going very well.
We see -- the women that I see,
they're at the vanguard of this,
would be the people I'd
want fighting with me
if I were wearing a uniform
in the army right now.
They are impressive.
They're dedicated.
And they, more than anybody
else, want to make sure
that the requirements are set and
that they meet the requirements.
>> Colleen Shogan: Mm-hmm.
>> Eric Fanning: And sexual assault?
Yeah, I think -- you know,
there were a lot of titles
that were mentioned
in my introductions.
Some of them were at the same time,
but I've had nine different
jobs in this Administration.
And so I've seen this from every
single corner of the Pentagon.
And I do think it's been a --
it's been something we'll spend --
I wouldn't say it's
been a priority of mine.
It's been a priority of ours to
focus on this and get this right.
It's critical that we get
at this and that we --
you know, we are held to a higher
standard, and we should be.
And we need to meet
that higher standard.
And I think where my focus has been
in the last year with the Army,
the last year plus, has been --
we have done a lot on
the response aspect,
making sure that lawyers are
changed, judges are changed.
We have victims' advocates.
But we need to make that
whole aspect irrelevant
by getting at the prevention part.
And that's been really my focus
the last 18 months as I've moved
through the Army jobs as investing
in that part of our organization,
pushing the team on the
research and on programs to get
at the prevention part
which is harder.
But I think we're making
some progress there.
>> Colleen Shogan: Terrific.
Well, if you hadn't
noticed, in the past couple
of weeks we had a Presidential
Election and I --
you know, I think it was a very
divisive Presidential Election.
And one of the, I think,
good results out of it is
that people are trying
to stay positive
in their personal interactions
with each other and also online
and social media, so I want to ask
a very positive question of you.
I've been asking you a
lot of hard questions.
We're going to celebrate
Thanksgiving in two days,
so what are you most
thankful for this year?
>> Eric Fanning: Well,
my [inaudible] --
my answer to that is
the traditional one.
But I felt it acutely over the
course of the last couple of years
with confirmation processes and
movements and what have you.
And that's my friends and my family.
I had -- you know, two years
ago now I was Undersecretary
of the Air Force.
The Secretary of the Air
Force is one of my oldest,
closest, dearest friends.
She worked on the House
Armed Services Committee
with me, and just loving life.
And Ash Carter, who I've known
for 25 years, came knocking
and sets off a 12-month period
where I'm in five different jobs
as I moved from the Air Force to
him to the Number Two in the Army
to the Acting Secretary of the
Army, then back to his office
because of the vagaries of
the confirmation process.
And if I didn't have that sort
of stability in those touchpoints
in my personal life it would have
been a much different 12 months.
>> Colleen Shogan: Well, you
have just a tremendous resume.
You've sat in all these very
impressive seats in the Pentagon.
Can I ask you, what's
next in your career?
What are the next steps?
And where do you think your skills
will be best utilized in the future?
>> Eric Fanning: Well, I,
you know, I think I have one
of the greatest jobs in the world
that very few people
really understand the role
of the Service Secretary which
is one of the reasons it's
such a great job, because
they kind of leave you alone.
Generally, if you get a call,
it's -- something bad has happened
and you got to deal with it.
But the autonomy that you get
as Service Secretary is great.
And the way I describe it is
being the CEO of a business unit.
I mean, I'm the CEO of the Army.
The Army is a unbelievably
lethal war-fighting machine
and a tool of national power.
The Department of the Army is a
business unit that creates it.
And it's -- and so when I -- and the
confirmation process now having gone
through it twice -- it takes a lot
out of people who go through it.
And I had it relatively easy
compared to a lot of people.
And so I said when I get through
this and get into this job
that I love so much, I'm
going to focus on that job
until they drag me
out of the building.
And then I'm going to take a long
break someplace warm and then think
about what it is I want to do next.
I didn't want to waste any --
there's so much you want to do in
organization of 1.4 million people
that -- in 150 countries in
the world, that I didn't want
to take a lot of time thinking
about what's next and then --
and any two conversation you have
you got to report to the lawyers
and then life gets
complicated for you.
So, you know, my plan is to
do this as long as I'm needed
and then go catch my breath.
>> Colleen Shogan: Thank
you for your service.
Now's the time in the program
that, if we have questions
from the audience, we'd
be happy to take them.
Yes. Up front.
>> How many Army [inaudible]
services?
How should we [inaudible]?
>> Eric Fanning: Well, I'm
Secretary of the Army so, no,
it shouldn't be that way [laughter].
Well, you know, the -- it's,
it's not really a third.
It is substantially less than
the Navy and the Air Force.
Now they're building
these enormous platforms.
The Army doesn't have aircraft
carriers or nuclear bombers
or joint strike fighters.
Those programs cost more money.
But I do think that the
Army's -- and, you know what?
I've worked through
all those departments.
See, they're struggling as well.
And if you think we're
out of balance now,
look 10 years into the future
for the military budget.
The entire nuclear apparatus
needs to be modernized
or capitalized at the
exact same time.
Usually you want that
phased a little bit.
New bombers are going to be
coming on line, new warheads,
entirely new missile system for the
Air Force, new ballistic submarines.
That's not -- there isn't a
plan on how to pay for that yet.
So those services have
their own balance,
programmatic balance issues.
The Army is by far the best balance,
and that just means you've got risk
evenly applied across your budget.
But I would argue that we need to
increase the modernization budget
for the Army because when I look --
the current plan is to
modernize existing platforms,
but in a timeframe that exceeds
how long we'd ever plan on keeping
and holding on some
of these platforms.
So I don't look at it
as how it's balanced
in the pie with the other services.
I just think about the pie itself
for the entire Department
of Defense.
I mean one of the things I do, as
I've moved through these jobs --
it is never going to win an
argument if the Army starts
out by comparing itself to
the Air Force, the Navy,
and some way that they're
hoping makes them look better.
It just never catches water
on the Hill or with OSD.
But we do have some bills
we've pushed into the future,
and it's not just modernization.
It's installations, too.
We're under-investing
year after year after year
in installations and, you know,
it's a certain amount of money
to maintain a building, a
certain amount to repair it,
and then a lot more to replace it,
which is what's starting to happen.
>> Colleen Shogan: Up front.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> -- on climate change,
a national security issue.
And, of course, the President
has [inaudible] directives
on that, on that [inaudible].
Do you think that that is
the thing that is now baked
into [inaudible] department
[inaudible] or do you think
that will [inaudible]
next administration?
>> Eric Fanning: I don't know
what the next administration
because I'm not a part
of those conversations.
But I do think it's baked
into the Department of Defense
in a way that's enduring,
and for two reasons.
We are already seeing it impact
our installations, you know.
Where are Navy bases?
They're on shores.
And so we're already seeing
issue in the Army, in the Navy,
in the Marine Corps, in the Air
Force, with our installations.
But, you know, anybody who looks at
the threatened environment of the --
or the geopolitical environment
of the future has got to see
that the other -- the effects
of climate change also are going
to create all sorts of instability
that we're going to
have to deal with.
So I do think it feels pretty
baked in for me and it's not just
on the political side
in this Administration.
It's in numerous strategy documents
that we've been creating
over the last few years.
>> Colleen Shogan: Yes, mm-hmm.
>> Excuse me.
>> Colleen Shogan: Mm-hmm.
>> Hi [inaudible].
What are your top priorities for the
last couple of months of your term?
And do you have any concerns
about how an Administration
change might change the direction
that the Army's headed?
>> Eric Fanning: My priorities
for the end are the Rapid
Capabilities Office.
In the next couple of weeks we
will finalize the first round
of actual investments
for that office.
That is a priority.
I want to keep talking
about behavioral health
and see what more I can do to
keep moving in that direction,
the paradigm shift
that I talked about.
And then I'm very proud of the
different ways that we have opened
up service to those who've been
denied the opportunity in the past,
and continuing to make sure
that that's going smoothly
will be an important part
of whatever time that I have left.
And, you know, I think, you know,
the dramatic changes that I've seen
in my career with the Department
of Defense is, you know,
when I said I'm the CEO of business
unit, again, I create a product.
Other people decide how
to use that product.
I'm way oversimplifying, of course.
But that's where you get dramatic
changes from one government
to another which is how you're
the military in the context
of foreign policy and all the
tools you've got in the toolbox.
It's a complex world out there
with lots of threats swirling.
And so, you know, I'm not sure what
the new Administration will decide
and how they want to tackle
some of those problems.
>> Colleen Shogan:
In back [inaudible].
>> Hi. Scott Moucione
with Federal News Radio.
Talent management has been something
that Ash Carter's really
been focusing on.
And I think he's been bringing up
some of the promotion board issues.
The Army was in the news
with promotion boards
because Lieutenant Riley, who was
a Rhodes Scholar, was almost passed
over for his promotion board until
Chief of Staff Milley got involved.
I was just wondering, you know,
one, do you think that the next --
whoever's going to be in charge
of the Army next will be able
to recognize that problem since
the Force of the Future has had
such problems with Republicans.
And, two, what more do you
plan to do in the realm
of talent management
in your final days?
>> Eric Fanning: I think there
are certain issues we're working
on that -- some might
choose a different approach.
But I feel like there's
a shared recognition
that the issues are important.
Force of the Future -- the Force
of the Future initiatives
I think are important at --
you know Secretary Carter's
imagining what a workforce is going
to look like in 20 years,
and doesn't necessarily see
that the Department of Defense is
going to be an attractive place
as it exists now for people to work
at, to work for, and I think some
of these changes are important.
But it's broader than just changing
-- you know, our uniform workforce
and our career civilian workforce,
I think we have to think very --
we have to think much
more creatively
about what a workforce
is and how we access it.
And it might be temporary.
It's how we interact with
industry differently,
with academia differently.
I think we've got to get much more
creative at breaking down barriers
which is really what
he's focused on.
General Milley and I have talked
a lot about talent management
on the uniform side, and I think
there are some relatively easy fixes
to get at some of these things so
that a lieutenant who's got a degree
from Oxford, is a Rhodes
Scholar, doesn't get passed over.
And part of that is just maybe
allowing a little bit more time
in the process.
The Army is massive and these boards
move through names very quickly
and so some of that
nuance can be lost.
And Secretary Carter's
been focused on trying
to give people opportunities,
development,
career development opportunities,
broadening opportunities.
But we still have these poll years
and it could be hard for people
in uniform to take a year or two
years and actually believe that --
they may come back onto the
track they're not going to be --
their career advance is
not going to be hindered.
And so we're looking at ways
to make sure that those --
that people who take advantage
of those opportunities, that,
that it impacts in a
positive way their career
and their career trajectory.
>> Colleen Shogan: A question.
Mark, mm-hmm.
>> Secretary, you spoke about --
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
How do you see the role --
>> Eric Fanning: So I --
you know, it's interesting.
I start in the date -- it's probably
the Navy which has to two services.
And as one Admiral described them,
yes, they're sister services,
the Navy and Marine Corps,
but they're orphan children
adopted in separate families.
And then I go to the Air Force and
think, okay, now I've got it easy.
It's one service.
And then I run into the
politics of the Guard.
Then I think I have it all
figured out and I go to the Army
and we have the Corps of Engineers
which is then a whole
other political grab-bag.
But first is we cannot do
what we're asked to do.
The Army cannot do what it's
asked to do if it doesn't think
as a total force and
work as efficiently
and effectively as a total force.
The act of [inaudible] just couldn't
do everything that's being of it.
Second of all, people join the
Guard for different reasons today
than they did 15 years ago.
One thing I keep reminding -- a lot
of these issues that we focus on,
we do with -- are really
generational.
And 911 was a call to
service for a lot of people.
People who join the Guard want
to be operational in a way
that I don't think was necessarily
the same case 40 years ago.
And so a [inaudible] formed
leadership may be remembered
as an older Guard.
The, you know, colonels now,
like my colonels in the back,
they know the new Guard,
because you go downrange now.
You go out into the field, you
can't tell whether someone's Guard,
Reserve, or Active unless you ask.
And then the more junior officers,
on a lot of issues, this being one
of them, just look at me like I'm
crazy for even asking the question,
like we're already doing it.
And so the future of the
Guard is integral to the Army.
And I think we're getting much
better at all of the different --
it can be very political because
the governors have an agenda
for the Guard, we have an agenda
for the Guard, the Adjutant Generals
of the Guard -- you know, there's
the Guard Bureau, there's the Hill.
Someone once described the active
Army as the President's Army
and the Guard is Congress's Army.
But we've set up a lot of mechanisms
to increase communication
and collaboration.
And, you know, it got so bad
that the Air Force was asked --
that the Congress stood
up a commission
on the future of the Air Force.
And I was in the Air Force and
got to live through that and moved
over to the Army just
in time to deal
with the Army's Commission
on the Future.
But one of the things
that came out of
that is this thing called
the Council of Governors.
And it's been a very effective
mechanism with about 10 governors
and Department of Defense leadership
and DHS leadership to work
through these issues because, going
back to what I said at the start,
we cannot do what we're
asked to do if we don't think
of ourselves as a total force.
>> Colleen Shogan: I think we
have time for one more question.
Right up here, mm-hmm.
>> So if you look at the
[inaudible] going back
over the last quarter century,
it looks like there's
a pretty clear pattern.
And if you read budget documents
published at very institutions
around town, you'd see
the same pattern which is
that pretty much any given force
structure the United States has
seems to somehow require annual real
increases in defense spending of 2-
or 3% to sustain it, no matter
what, year-in, year-out.
So, given how much management
experience you've had,
what's the story on this because I
can't really find a consistent story
on why this appears to be the case.
>> Eric Fanning: Well,
a couple of things.
If I just broaden that
a little bit and say --
I think there's a few
reasons for that.
One is we don't manage that way.
We don't manage -- if --
you know, in my experience
in the last eight years we haven't
even managed with annual budgets.
Wonder [inaudible]
resolution right now.
We've started every single year
with a continuing resolution
which is a very disruptive and
expensive way to govern, to manage.
If we really took a 25-year
period, snapped the chalk line,
and then went 2- to 3% by year,
you'd get more out of your budget,
out of your program, I think,
than the way we manage now
where there's no predictability,
there's no reliability
to the budget.
You can't manage the
Department of Defense
on a series of 12-month cycles.
You certainly -- you know, it's very
difficult to manage in our series
of three-month and
then nine-month cycles.
And now we're going to get
a continuing resolution
that takes us in, you know,
probably into six months.
That costs a lot of
money to govern that way.
And people don't understand
the impacts.
This will be the first
administrative transition
under a continuing resolution.
And what a -- and people --
my predecessor, John McHugh,
was a Member of Congress
for many years.
And he said he thought
a CR was a good thing
because it kept the spigot open.
Well, all it does is let you
spend what you spent last year.
So if you've got any new
program in your budget,
you're not authorized
to spend on it.
What does that do to your people?
What does it do to contracts?
What does it do to
the industrial brace.
It adds costs year after
year after year to operate
in such fiscal confusion.
And I -- to me, that's
a big part of it.
Now, the 25-year period,
the Berlin Wall falls,
we took a knee a little bit
because you decide, okay,
the world is stable enough that
I can take a little bit of risk
and invest in something different.
We haven't been able to do
that these last 15 or 20 years.
We haven't had -- we haven't been
able to take that balance where,
okay, we've got a little
bit less risk geopolitically
so we can take some risks
in being ready in order
to invest in modernization.
And you kind of balance
that out over these curves
in a 25-or-longer-year period.
So we haven't had that.
And we've had -- we start --
we end every fiscal year
preparing for a shutdown.
A very inefficient
operation environment
for the military the
last eight years.
>> Colleen Shogan: Mr. Secretary, on
behalf of the Library of Congress,
thank you for your
time this morning.
And most importantly,
thank you for your service.
And we wish you the best of luck.
>> Eric Fanning: Thank you.
Thanks very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.